- Yeah, just to kick this off,
today we're gonna be
looking at log analytics
and log management through
the power of Dynatrace
and the power of Davis AI.
So looking at how we can do log
analytics at petabyte scale,
ingest, and precise root cause analysis.
And we've got a really interesting story
to sort of back this up as
well from from Alex here,
from Storio group, and also
of course with the partnership
that we have here with AWS, and again,
how of course Dynatrace, AWS,
and of course our customers
that we have together,
work hand in hand.
So I am Jon Griffiths.
I'm the field CTO at Dynatrace,
covering primarily Europe,
Middle East, and Africa.
And...
- My name is Alex Hibbitt.
I'm a engineering director.
I'm responsible for the customer
platform of Storio group.
- And I'm Frank Schwarzenau.
I'm the global lead for
the observability use case
for AWS Partner Specialists.
And yeah, let you start now.
- No worries.
- Back in a second.
- So
as we sort of started on,
we'll look at first Dynatrace and AWS
and that partnership together,
and how we sort of enable
customers to innovate,
move faster, and of course reduce
their mean time to resolution
and resolve an instance.
We'll then move on to Alex
with the interesting story
around Storio group's journey
with log analytics,
and how they've made
massive changes around that.
And then finally, touching on
actually modern log management,
the sort of things that
you can learn from that,
how we can look at, you know,
significant cost savings
a lot of the time,
the sort of 60 to 70%
reduction in log spend
while still getting even more
significant value out of that.
So I'll start with Dynatrace.
How many of you here, let's say,
are a customer of Dynatrace?
Okay, reasonable amount.
How many of you here work for
a competitor of Dynatrace?
No?
Ah, there's a couple.
Security? No.
Okay.
Now, as a whole, basically,
Dynatrace, for those
that aren't fully aware,
focuses on observability and
security with AI at its core.
Now, what that ends up
meaning is that all data,
all signals, whether that's the logs,
whether that's metrics, traces,
whether that's from your
infrastructure, your applications,
the real users, your AI agents or LLMs,
whatever it may be,
getting all of that
deep insight in context.
And the context is key,
because whenever you look at
things like automation or AI,
good-quality data is is called to that.
You know, rubbish data, rubbish output;
good-quality data obviously allows you
to have far better outputs
associated with that.
Now, again, when you
start to make decisions
and data-driven decisions,
again, data, context,
and especially the domain
context that comes into that
can be very crucial to this.
So really, Dynatrace is
providing that deep insight
in the context of your
domain, in the context
of wherever it's grabbing
that information from,
so that, as you can see here,
we like to say that we'll help
you understand your business
like never before.
Now, again, obviously a
few quick slides first,
but we are obviously
leading in this market.
As you can see here, this is
the Gartner Magic Quadrant,
where the most recent one
we've been in the highest
ability to execute,
and ranked number one
in four of the six critical capabilities.
And finally, on there, as you can see,
we are the only vendor to have been named
in every single Gartner Magic Quadrant
for APM and observability
since its inception.
So we've been in that leader
quadrant in every single one.
So that's 15 years of staying
in that leader quadrant.
Again, innovation and
continuously striving forwards
is obviously key to that.
And of course it's not just
the analyst side of things.
You know, we have customers
from every single industry.
You know, whether that's,
as you can see here,
things like aviation,
banking, retail, utilities,
and all across the board.
We have customers in every single industry
and across every single continent.
So again, really driving
that platform faster.
Obviously we are taking the
insights from our customers,
expanding obviously on our awareness
and ensuring that we are
innovating to keep up
and match what our
customers actually require.
Oh, Frank.
- That's my cue.
So as I said before,
my job at AWS is essentially just focusing
on the AWS observability use case
and working with both
ISVs and SI partners.
And we have about 120,000
partners in our network.
And of those 120,000 partners,
we have about 200 in our
cloud operations competency,
which includes observability.
And there's actually just eight
ISV observability partners
that are specialists or
deemed specialists from AWS
and got the stamp of approval
to be that observability partner.
So the 10 years of
partnership is a great number,
but it's more important to focus
on how much Dynatrace
is leaning in with AWS
and with the customers.
And that leaning in is
of course represented
by all of these competencies
that are achieved
in the bottom here,
which essentially are the
stamp of approval from AWS,
where Dynatrace jumps
through a lot of hoops
that we put out there in order
for you as a customer
to be able to say, like,
"Wow, Dynatrace, they really
know what they're doing
around all of these use cases."
But one exciting part of course
is how much Dynatrace is
leaning in on the AI use case
and is launching on, you know,
on a monthly basis something
like all of the integrations
with Bedrock AgentCore, for instance,
for end-to-end observability
for your agents.
Or even Kiro integrations for AI-assisted
troubleshooting through your IDE.
But also what's really important,
and I think what I always come across
is there's very few customers
that complain about Dynatrace,
which is really nice to see,
because I think, from my perspective,
and I see a lot of different
partner engagements
and a lot of different
customer engagements
without partners,
Dynatrace is really kind
of moving the needle
and really kind of
defining of what it means
to be customer-obsessed,
what it means to be aligned with AWS,
and provide that value throughout,
not just make migration easy,
but then also how does
the customer get value
out of using both AWS in the combination
with Dynatrace afterwards.
One of the cool things is
also the native integrations.
This is probably way over
a hundred at this point
because the slide is a few weeks old,
but we see Dynatrace really leaning in
on launching services together with us.
And being a launch partner,
we beat our customers for stuff
that you don't even know
it's around the corner yet.
But really kind of being tied at the hip.
And of course you were Global
Partner of the Year last year.
No, this year, 2025.
You were Technology Partner
of the Year in EMEA last year.
So I think there's a big recognition
from both the AWS environment
as well as from our customers.
Dynatrace leans in,
and I can talk about
each of these pillars.
So I hope everybody's
familiar with these pillars
from the Well-Architected Framework.
But of course you have,
you know, resilience,
you have resource optimization,
you have cost optimization,
you have performance optimization,
and SLA management and so on.
But the more important
fact about this slide
is that Dynatrace thinks about
the impact to the customer,
very much aligned with
how AWS thinks about
how to have impact with the customer,
so that it's gonna be easy
for all of us to work together
and talk around the same
kind of core concepts
and core guiding principles.
I talked about AI before
and how much Dynatrace is
leaning into these integrations.
This number here of 500
implementations (chuckles)
is actually just from the AI use case.
So we already have 500
wins that we have together,
where Dynatrace has enabled customers
to really leverage the
best of AWS and Dynatrace
to adopt the AI use cases.
And this is around or on all
different kind of layers.
So I think everybody here in
the room is pretty familiar
of how to do observability
or how observability should be done
on the application layer,
and probably also pretty familiar
with how it should be done
on the infrastructure layer.
But I think the important part
is sort of the wedge in between, you know,
on the orchestration level
where you have prompt observability,
or on the semantic layer
where you really can look at
how biased the inputs and the outputs are
when you interact with
your AI applications.
And then of course model health, you know,
how do you continuously monitor
the health of your models
that you use for your applications.
And then I mentioned this already,
Dynatrace launches a
lot of services with us,
and I'm always happy
when we are about to
launch another service,
and the Dynatrace DO is
putting up their hand, like,
"We would like to test it."
I'm like, "Perfect."
So that is happening continuously,
and it's a real joy to see
how much you guys are
leaning in on these things
and giving us feedback as well,
and sort of co-innovate together
in order to make this
easy for our customers.
Speaking of customers, this
is just a couple of metrics.
And it's quite interesting,
when I kind of dove deep on this one,
and eventually, essentially,
this is all essentially working
backwards to money, right?
So if you're reducing this time spent
on your resolutions,
if you're actually reducing
the overall number of incidents
or major incidents,
and if you just have
faster issue resolving
and higher uptime, in the end of the day,
all of this is boiling down to
customer happiness and money.
And this is just some really,
really impressive numbers.
And we're glad that
we're in this together.
And I can continue in talking and talking
about how much customer impact we have,
but we have a customer here
that we're both partnering with.
Alex, if you want to come up
and maybe tell your story.
- Absolutely. Thank you very much, Frank.
So
who here has heard of the
three pillars of observability?
Bit of an outdated term now,
but just a quick show of hands.
Yeah, a few of you.
I'm not gonna talk about
those three pillars of observability.
Instead, I'm gonna talk
about an alternative
three pillars of observability.
And these have come out
of our adoption journey
with Dynatrace.
I say adoption, it's in fact a readoption
because we'd worked with Dynatrace
in a previous iteration before.
I'm willing to bet most
of you have never heard
of Storio group though.
So Storio group is Europe's biggest
photo-gifting company by revenue.
We operate in about a dozen countries
under eight different brands,
some of which you may have heard of:
albelli, Photobox, Hofmann, posterXXL.
We serve over 7 million customers a year.
And in 2022 we delivered
over 10 million orders.
And we've been around
for quite a long while,
but not in the skies.
Our oldest brand is Hofmann,
and that's been in the Spanish market
for over a hundred years now.
So we've got some serious history.
But as Storio group, we've
only came together in 2021
as a merger of two different businesses.
albelli, who were based
in the Netherlands,
and Photobox who were a
group based in the UK.
When we joined together,
we had a massive challenge.
Immediately post-merger, we
looked around our ecosystem,
and we had something like five different
technology platforms
providing, largely speaking,
the same customer experience,
selling photo gifts to end users.
Any organization looking
to innovate and make change
cannot do so when they've
got to do things five times
to roll out one feature.
So we really had a huge
call to action there,
and that call to action was how do we move
into one singular platform?
We also had huge scale to deal with.
Across all of those platforms,
we had over 11 petabytes'
worth of customer data:
that's customer photos,
or memories as we like to refer to them.
We really needed to go on a
massively imperative journey
to reduce the duplication we had,
down from those five platforms
to one singular platform.
And that journey took
up two and a half years,
that first two and a half
years of our journey together,
and exclusive focus, exclusive
and probably ruthless focus.
When we got to the final point
of having one singular platform,
we took a breath for a
moment and looked around
and realized that we had
made many, many trade-offs,
as you have to do when you're on a journey
of such complexity and such pressure.
We previously had a really
mature observability posture
when we were the Photobox
half of the organization.
And the albelli half of the organization
had had a bit of a different strategy.
And when we took moment and we had a look,
we said there are some
things missing here.
We had a platform that
was strongly human-heavy.
It was very, very log-centric.
And with that we looked
at our MTTR and our MTTD,
two core metrics,
and realized that they were
trending in a direction
that we did not like.
MTTR was going massively up,
and simultaneously the number of incidents
we were tracking was dropping.
To me that meant that we were losing track
of what was happening on our platform.
We were not observing as much
as we had previously been
in our Photobox iteration.
To give you an example, Black
Sunday, as we like to call it,
which is yesterday, the
biggest trading day of the year
for photo-gifting companies,
we were looking at engineers
manually trying to
correlate performance data
and understand what was going wrong
across 1.1 billion individual log lines.
Humans looking at that much data
are going to miss not just
one thing, not just 10 things,
but hundreds of things.
And it was intensely resource-intensive
in terms of the computational power needed
and the human power needed,
and it was fundamentally not
solving the problem we had.
The challenge with this
was it created a massive
business risk for us.
Like many businesses,
Black Friday through to the holiday season
is a hugely important period for us.
Across those six weeks,
an outage would've cost us something like,
at any random point it
hit, at least $274,000.
But during our peak hours, yesterday,
as I was flying over here,
I was watching the numbers come in;
we trade up to one and
a half million dollars,
million euros, an hour.
That's a huge number, bearing in mind
that an incident takes on average,
when we were looking at
our observability adoption,
an hour and a half to resolve.
You're talking about way over
two million euros' worth of trading
suddenly blown up by an incident.
That huge risk meant that this
became a massive imperative
to the business.
We needed to reorient what we were doing
and make sure we became the first to know
when trouble was brewing.
So this brings me onto our first
pillar: the culture pillar.
The core problem we had, if
you remember a minute ago,
was that we had engineers
who fundamentally were looking at logs
to work out when things were going wrong.
What that meant was our engineers
couldn't answer the meaningful
question: What broke?
Why did it break?
And how do we fix it?
And one of the biggest challenges we found
was that was in fact a mindset
that many of our engineers did
not understand was a problem.
They thought that this was actually
quite a good way of operating.
They built these amazingly
huge Elasticsearch clusters
and then OpenSearch clusters,
which are great for sorting
through tons of information,
but when you're trying to manually read
all of that information,
you're going to miss things.
We also had a challenge
around how do we deliver
meaningful change to that culture.
Our Anglo-Dutch engineering organization
had a strong sense of its own identity
and was very proud, quite rightly,
of what they had built out
in terms of the technology platform.
And what that meant was people like me
couldn't wander in and
say, "Oh, this is rubbish."
I would've lost all
credibility by doing that.
It would've been interpreted as top-down.
So what we needed to do is take
our engineers on a journey,
something that we've
jokingly started referring to
as the start to the 12-step
program of observability.
First of all, we needed
to help them understand
they had a problem.
It wasn't just me wandering along
saying that this is rubbish.
Each engineer needed to look
at the situation they had
and say, "This is something
that we can make better."
And then we had to help them
become part of the solution.
So let's talk about how we got there.
First thing we did was we
built out a small working group
of five influential engineers
across the organization
who were strong advocates that
we did not have a problem,
the actual people we wanted to persuade.
We asked them to start
looking across the market,
understanding what industry text,
industry research looked like,
doing some internal surveys
and looking at reports
like Gartner and Forrester
to understand what the modern world
of observability looked like.
And then we asked them to
translate all of that data
into a maturity model.
This maturity model rather
handily aligns quite nicely
with Dynatrace's maturity model.
It allowed our teams to grade
where they were in observability,
but with a particular Storio flavor to it.
It was quite quick to identify
that we were operating around
the Level 1, Level 2 position,
that monitoring to base-level
observability space,
when in fact our desire was
to be way up to the Level 3,
if not the Level 4 place in
that causal observability
and proactive observability space.
It also meant that by
building this piece out,
we had a framework, we had a direction,
we knew we wanted to get
to that Level 4 position,
but we knew that we were gonna
have to go through Level 2
and Level 3 to get there.
So we suddenly had a clear
direction to that North Star.
This brings me on to our technology solve.
So I mentioned we were shipping
1.1 billion logs a day.
That was largely coming from
a containerized workload.
We use ECS as our container
orchestration platform.
It's a fairly straightforward solve
when you're looking at shipping
logs from that solution.
AWS provides a product called FireLens,
which is a fantastic
sidecar to your ECS stacks.
It can simply take your existing logs,
and it outputs them using
Fluent Bit as a protocol
that can be ingested
directly by an active gate,
which is Dynatrace's
technology for routing metrics,
logs, and other pieces
into their ecosystem.
And then from there it
can be fed into Grail,
which is Dynatrace's
unified data lakehouse.
Try saying that after a drink or two.
We also had quite a lot
of workload in Lambda;
about 40% of our workload
lives in the Lambda ecosystem.
Again, quite a straightforward solve.
CloudWatch Log groups can be subscribed
into a Kinesis Firehose,
and then that can be
taken off to OpenPipeline,
again, a Dynatrace technology
for pulling material in
and doing transforms on it.
That let us do some preprocessing
and then load that into Grail.
So we've now got all of our
logs from our ECS workload
and all of our logs
from our Lambda workload
flowing nicely into Dynatrace.
Last step was our more
legacy EC2 workload.
We already had an in-place
OTel implementation for that,
and again that was a very
straightforward solve.
We were able to ship
all of that OTel data,
logs and the traces that we had present,
over into Dynatrace, directly
into Dynatrace's API,
and now we've got all
of our 1.1 billion logs
in one singular clear platform.
Simple, right?
This brings us onto pillar number two.
Once we got there,
we started putting our logs into context,
and we immediately started seeing value
from the Dynatrace platform.
We were suddenly seeing events
happening on our platform
being correlated together
in an automagic way.
Brilliant, if you bear in mind,
pastly, we've been doing
that using humans and saying,
"Well, this log and this
log over here correlate."
We're getting that
correlation out of the box
and we're beginning to
understand what's going on.
But it also exposed to us
that we were often using
the wrong signal bearer,
in this particular case, logs,
in situations where something
like another signal bearer
would be a better fit.
A great example is trying
to piece together elements
from a set of calls using logs,
when in fact in reality
you may be able to display
that better using tracers.
Once we had those logs in context,
we could start saying,
"Right, these are the
places in our ecosystem
where this signal does not fit.
Let's replace it with a different signal.
Let's replace this one with some traces.
Let's replace these
ones with some metrics."
And we started to get a richer experience,
as well as simultaneously
decreasing our log volume.
And we started dropping
that 1.1 billion down
into the several hundred
millions and so on downwards.
We also started being able to visualize
for the first time, in a visual way,
these connections between
our distributed services.
So no longer was each
individual distributed service
an isolated little monolith
sat there doing its own thing.
We could see those calls propagating
from service to service.
This set ourselves up
with massive success.
We had this foundation of logs,
but we knew that we would
have to build on it.
And we consciously went out
and made sure that that foundation of logs
was not our end state.
For us, this meant that data unification,
as we like to call it,
moving all of our data into one place
and then picking out the right
signals was a nonnegotiable.
If we wanted to meaningfully
decrease our MTTD and our MTTR,
we had to go on this journey.
Let's talk about AI.
So as we heard earlier,
AI is a core part of
the Dynatrace platform.
Even with our signals now
getting into the millions
rather than the billions territory,
and with all of our noise filtered out
and using the correct barriers,
this would've still
been an impossible task
to look at manually using humans.
We'd known that from day one.
We thought it would be a Sisyphean task.
We would be pushing that
rock up a hill every day
as we work through our
peak trading period.
We knew that for any
system at scale to work,
we needed automation.
And that's what the combination
of predictive and causal AI
that is present within Dynatrace,
the Davis ecosystem, brought to us.
We started to see predictive
bringing in autobaselining.
So we were no longer having to work out
what our signals looked
like from a normal position,
set up manual thresholds,
et cetera, et cetera.
That just happened magically.
We also saw causal AI
starting to understand
the interconnected web
of services we have.
And we've got quite a few microservices
within our ecosystem, over 200.
Manually building out a web
of how these services talk to one another
would've been an impossible task.
But the automated nature of Dynatrace
and Davis operating started connecting
all of these services
together fantastically.
We made a conscious decision
to stop manually setting
up thresholds and alerts
and everything else,
and instead focus on making
the best out of Davis
and the problem cards we could do,
because we knew that that would
be the most impactful thing
in our MTTD.
To give you an example of this,
yesterday, at around about
8:00 PM European time,
we had what would've been
three Severity 1 incidents
start to emerge on our platform,
things we've not considered.
We had no,
as a result of having not considered them,
no ability to have instrumented
and consciously set up thresholds
for checking on these things,
so as we could have
been proactive about it.
But Davis was able to spot them coming,
start raising performance challenges
around a set of services,
and we averted three individual incidents.
Each one of those incidents alone
would've been a 1 1/2 million euro outage.
So in one single fell swoop,
the Dynatrace platform in Davis identified
over 4 1/2 million euros' worth of savings
to us, effectively.
I'm gonna talk you through a scenario
we had a little while ago
that also brings some light to this.
As you may know, in Europe,
each country has different territories
and different VAT rates that apply to it,
in particular when you're doing
territory-to-territory transactions.
We store all of that data
in a giant DynamoDB table.
Not the most elegant of solutions,
but we had to accept imperfections
as we went on our platform journey.
There is also no update method
nor any validation in place
for that particular DynamoDB table.
Again, hold my hands up, not
best engineering practice.
One of our product managers
was meaningfully applying
some updates to our tax rates,
but unfortunately, bit of
finger trouble crept in
and she managed to malform
one of the tax rates
for our German markets.
Davis immediately started
detecting an increase in failures,
of course that DynamoDB table,
and was even able to identify the lines
in that DynamoDB table that
were causing the failure.
We'd just been through a fairly
substantial reorganization,
and the team who actually
owned that service
had only been owning it
for the spell of two weeks.
But they were guided exactly
to where the problem lay.
They understood very immediately
it was related to this DynamoDB table
and a particular change that had happened
within the last 20 minutes,
and they were able to roll back
using point-in-time recovery
to a period before that
change had been made
and restore service within 20 minutes.
Bear in mind we'd done
nothing to build out alerting
for this particular scenario.
So this was all automation
firing off the back
and building out the meaningful
impact that we needed to see
to prevent any impact
happening to our customers.
We were able to solve this
problem within 20 minutes,
and we were really, really
glad of the investment
that we'd made in this space.
There were challenges, though.
We didn't always have some smooth sailing.
We realized that our
existing OTel implementation
combined with Dynatrace left
some things to be desired,
in particular around the
front end to backend space.
That mixed OTel and native ecosystem
is a super hard problem to solve for.
We also found that some of our engineers
who were still in that old-school mindset
of wanting to look at
logs and nothing else
really struggle with our new mindset.
To this day I have two engineers
who have differing views
on the value of logs
versus other signals in our ecosystem.
Each is right and each is valid,
but as we look to move things forward,
the opportunity to use other signals
is one that I think is
really, really valuable.
And lastly, we needed a
major time-bound event
to really bring our organization aligned
around that single goal.
For us, it's our peak trading period,
this run-up to the Black Friday weekend,
and then the run-up to the holiday period.
It laser-focused everybody in
on making a meaningful change.
And we've seen a massive acceleration
over these last couple of months,
since I started writing these slides,
to getting to a point
of having massively great
observability coverage.
So let me talk about some
of our key takeaways.
First of all, our change
had to be culture first,
code second.
Leading with the culture piece
is what has enabled us to
be powerful in our change.
If we'd have tried to introduce
the technology solution
or a process-driven solution first,
we would've failed on this journey.
We had to change our culture
before we could meaningfully
make improvement.
We also had to embrace the
idea of using other signals.
If we only stuck with our logs world,
we would be having a better experience,
but we would be missing so much value
that a modern observability
platform provides.
And that really, when you
get to a certain scale,
you need to use AI.
You can no longer rely on the
humans in your organization
to do the great job that they have done,
because there will be so much data;
even with the best will in the world,
they will not be able to keep up.
AI is essential to enable
engineering productivity.
You do not want your engineers
spending their time reading logs.
You want them there writing code.
And for that you need AI to help you
with that problem of analysis.
Okay, I think I am handing
back over to Jon now.
- Thank you, Alex.
So hopefully we all found
that very interesting.
It was a very good story,
and obviously some very good examples
about how log analytics
and the wider sort of
observability ecosystem
can empower things if
done in the right way.
Now, what we want to sort
of start delving into
and looking at a little bit more here,
so I just realized there's
a squeaky footboard here,
is the traditional log
management side of things
really need reinvention.
It doesn't work in the way
that it needs to nowadays.
things are scaling too much,
the ecosystem getting too complex;
and the more and more
complex your ecosystems get,
the more data they emit.
And obviously, Alex touched on
various of these points here,
but obviously some of them,
with things like inflated costs,
you are having that incredible
amount of technical debt
with these different traditional
log management tooling
that's out there;
not just in terms of
things like licensing,
but more in terms of things
like management and maintenance,
whether that's off the
platforms themselves
or whether that's the tens
of thousands of dashboards
that you're potentially
setting up and looking at.
And obviously there
are thousands of alerts
that effectively create the alert storms
that you were talking about there as well.
Now,
with all of that, it then
comes onto that correlation,
that manual correlation
that you're having to do
to connect these different siloed signals
from different, different tools,
to bring those things together,
to try and work out
where that root cause is.
And again, that of course
has that knock-on impact
to a worse mean time to resolution
and overall worse collaboration
that's taking place between
the different teams,
'cause everybody has
their own source of truth.
And finally, of course,
that brings you onto the
high-complexity side,
because overall the traditional
log management tooling
obviously has been around for
a very long space of time.
It is built in reality for the past.
It doesn't scale in the way that is needed
for the current world with microservices,
with AI agents and so on,
where it is dynamic, it
is massively scalable,
and it is cloud-native.
Because with all of those
you need to understand how they relate.
You need to understand
all the different signals,
and unfortunately logs by
itself isn't effective.
Logs as part of a much wider piece
with all of the other signals
is where things can be
most effectively used.
So when you bring those things together,
you can start to use
the appropriate signals
for their appropriate means
and utilize them all in the right way.
So with Dynatrace, what we're trying to do
is help you scale that cost effectively,
to unify and contextualize all that data,
whether that's the log
data with the topology,
with the metrics, the events.
You know, again,
whether that's the security
side of things as well,
bringing everything together
so you can understand that
all in a single place.
But more importantly, to
enable that proactiveness,
enable AI-driven decisions to be made
and automation to take place.
So really what we're looking at here
is that we all know that the applications,
your cloud environments and so on,
are getting bigger and more complex.
But with that explosion of data,
with the petabytes of logs,
metrics, traces and so on,
it then starts to be a question
of what can you do with it?
Where is the power with that?
And with automation and AI,
it's really trying to utilize that data,
not as effectively noise
or a burden of you having
to work on all of that
to understand what's
going wrong and so on,
but actually trying to
drive automation around it,
actually trying to drive
preventative operations,
empower your teams with the
automation on the back of that,
so that really you can turn your data,
your petabytes and
petabytes of information
really into a business advantage,
a competitive advantage.
And so when we're trying to
unify the data across the board,
unify the logs with the rest
of the observability signals,
with Dynatrace, we
obviously try and make that
as simple and as automated as possible.
One of our primary ways of
course is our Dynatrace OneAgent
which will automatically detect the logs
that you're say operating systems
and applications and so on
are writing out,
be able to automatically ingest those.
But of course it's not just
places you've got OneAgent;
maybe you've got OpenTelemetry
and you've got your
OpenTelemetry logs coming in.
Maybe you've got log shippers
like Fluent Bit and Fluentd and so on.
And bringing all that information in
in whichever way is relevant,
and of course the core one
here as well being, you know,
that direct integration with AWS,
getting all that log information from AWS
through the Firehose.
So again, you can understand
and bring the data in
no matter where it's sitting.
And again, between the
combination of your cloud estates
and your on-premise.
So really, you are
getting that unified view.
Now, what we're then doing
is we're effectively storing
that in our central storage
which we call Grail.
So that's effectively specifically built
for observability, data lakehouse.
And this does allow you to ingest
over a petabyte of
information every single day
into your environments
and have that full power.
Now, what you're able to
do with this, as I said,
is ensure that all data
is stored in there.
You know, whether that's
your logs, metrics, traces,
real user monitoring, whatever it may be,
all stored in context with one another.
Whether it's your log
records and your traces,
we know exactly which trace
has written which log record.
So you're not having to
look through log files
and just look at endless log files,
not knowing what connects to what;
you know exactly which
log record was written
by which trace, which was
connected to which user
in their browser or mobile app.
And we're trying to do this, as I said,
in the most automated way possible
and giving you as much
access as possible as well.
So there's no data storage
tiers for you to manage.
There's no hot and cold storage,
there's no rehydration of data.
You can parse literally the data on read.
So there's no semantics that
you have to previously set up.
There's no indexing and so on and so forth
that you have to set up beforehand.
You can parse that on read.
And what that ends up meaning
is that no matter your
question, no matter what it is,
no matter whether you've
thought of it beforehand,
you can always ask that question.
You don't have to rehydrate data.
You don't have to index
data in appropriate ways
to ask those queries.
You can ask whatever you want,
because you can parse it
on read in near real time.
So really have responsive query
even when you are
looking at your terabytes
or petabytes of information.
And as you can see here, you know,
we are able to do that at that
low ingest cost and retention
and still be able to
retain data up to 10 years.
All of that types of data you
can retain up to 10 years.
So whether that's, you know,
for regulatory standpoints,
you know, with things like
obviously some of the AI regulations
that have been coming
out across the world,
and, you know, obviously some
of the financial services,
especially regulations,
there is a lot of areas
where things like your audit logs
or, you know, your
generative AI connections
of your inputs and outputs and so on.
Understanding those and storing those
may be needed for that space of time.
And again, maybe quite
effective and useful.
But what do we do with all that data?
You know, once it's there,
it's not just about being able to view it
and show it dashboards;
really, this is where the power
of the AI really comes in.
So what we're looking at here
is AI is built into Dynatrace's core
and has been from the beginning.
And we are automatically mapping out
all of that topology information.
We are automatically mapping
out all your different services
and dependencies and everything together.
And all of those telemetry signals
are all mapped against those
topology components as well.
Now, what this means is
Dynatrace is then able to,
on top of all of that,
automatically baseline
and dynamically baseline as well,
full understanding to
automatically detect problems
that are taking place.
Because, at the end of the day,
you don't know what you don't know.
So you can't be setting up
or needing to set up alerts
for every single thing that
could possibly go wrong.
You need to just be told
when something goes wrong.
And then on top of that,
because of that accuracy of the data,
because of that contextualization,
that domain-level insights,
we're also able to provide
precise root cause analysis.
So effectively doing
fault tree-style analysis
so that you are able to get
accurate root cause analysis
rather than effectively
trying to correlate
different events together.
Now, what this means is you're
not getting the alert storms;
you're getting the full insights you need,
you're getting straight to the pinpoint
to be able to resolve those things,
but you're also able to prioritize
these on business impact.
You know, how many users are impacted,
how many business flows, or, you know,
critical business services
are actually impacted by this problem.
And because you've got
accurate root cause,
it also means you can do self-healing.
The issue with self-healing on
let's say general correlation
is always that with the
inherent false positives
that come in, if you try and automate
or remediate on a false positive,
you're going to make the
situation a lot worse.
Most of the time you'll
scale out your AWS instances
and give AWS a lot of
money to pay for that.
But overall it could be a matter
that you are restarting services
that didn't need restarting.
It could mean all sorts
of different things,
where, at the end of the day,
your customers are getting
the worst scenario,
and probably your costs
are also increasing too.
If you know exactly what went wrong,
you can fix the root cause
rather than trying to
fix the various symptoms
that often end up bubbling
up in these alert storms.
And as you'll see through
through these as well,
there is an example here
of a problem taking place
where there is a failure rate increase.
Now, with this, we are
able to have the Davis AI,
the generative AI part, the Davis Copilot
actually explain to you what happened
as part of that problem.
So it's not just a matter of giving you
all this technical information
and you working out what it is,
you're actually getting a
summary of that problem:
what happened, what took
place, why did it take place?
And an actionable set of steps
to actually go ahead and remediate that,
some suggestions on how to remediate that.
Now, what that means of course
is that you don't have to go
and make those reports quickly
when a major incident happens.
You know, you've got that
natural language interpretation
that can easily be put out
so that management and
whoever else is aware
of what's going on.
It also allows you to obviously
focus on the right areas,
in the right places to delve into that.
Now, in this case, it
was a recent deployment,
and so the suggestions here
is basically looking at
reviewing the error logs
and various things like that.
But what it's then able to do with that
is because we've got that
direct access to the logs,
we know exactly which logs
are relevant to that problem,
you know, it's not here's every log
that's relevant to these servers,
it is exactly the logs that
are relevant to this problem,
the logs that were specifically
part of that trace.
'Cause the thing that you'll often have
is you may look at a log file
that you know is relevant,
lots of error messages in there,
but which ones are actually
relevant to the transactions
that are failing, that are
actually having an issue.
'Cause error logs happen all the time,
and quite often you can
get that mismatching
of there are error logs,
I'm assuming that
they're gonna be relevant
to the problem that I'm looking at.
And in many times it's not,
and it leads you down the wrong
sort of rabbit hole as such.
Now, what we can effectively
do with that though is,
as I said, you've got the
visibility into all of the logs
that have taken place
as part of that problem,
and we can start to also
explain those logs as well.
So again, having Dynatrace
automatically tell you
what that log record
actually means, you know?
I'm sure all of you have
seen log lines before.
They vary massively.
Some of them are the
messiest things possible.
But it is able to extract out all
of the relevant information that's useful,
break it all down for you so
you haven't had to preparse it
and preconfigure it and
whatever else it may be;
you're able to be told exactly
what the key information is,
what the possible root cause is for that,
and of course, you know,
any actionable steps
to remediate the specifics of that.
Because this is where
logs are really good.
They're good at providing context.
They're not very good from an
observability point of view
of creating alerts and creating problems
because there is so much noise in logs.
But they are very good
at providing context
and providing you good insights
to actually go ahead
and start remediation.
And finally, on this piece as well,
the other thing that Dynatrace is doing
is we're also providing this
idea of troubleshooting guides.
So you can go ahead
and you can create a troubleshooting guide
based on that problem.
Obviously, you do all your
inputs and your queries
and whatever else it may be.
But the benefit of what's
taking place on this
is that when you have a problem
that occurs in the future that is similar,
Dynatrace will automatically recommend
the previous troubleshooting
guide that you created.
Because it's looking at the
similarity of those problems
and basically providing you
with the previous troubleshooting guide
so you're not having
to repeat those steps.
Again, it's really, as I said,
trying to maximize
automation wherever possible,
trying to reduce that manual effort,
that time it takes you
to resolve incidents,
and so you can get to the root cause
and resolve it as quickly as possible.
But it's not just about
fighting those fires.
You also want to look
at of course predicting
and preventing those fires
from taking place in the first place.
So when we look at
Dynatrace's predictive AI,
it can forecast on any
time-series data at all
that Dynatrace has.
That includes logs.
So you can literally do prediction
based on your log records directly.
Now, what this means is
you can start to understand
if things are trending
in the wrong direction,
and you can start to fix issues
before they actually have
any impact to your end users.
Now, we can effectively
start to drive automation
based on that, from the various
logs and events and so on.
So if Dynatrace detects, in this case,
that there's S3 buckets
that are open to the public internet,
we can of course
automatically remediate that.
You know, we can use AWS's
action APIs effectively
to auto-remediate and
change those S3 buckets
so that you can prevent
that sensitive data
before it ever gets leaked.
And we can also do things
like proactively scaling.
You know, whether you're scaling up
to increase capacity of
your disk, your memory,
your CPU, whatever it may be,
or if the logs are indicating
that there's a business-specific problem
or error that are taking place
due to maybe it's resource
saturation or something else,
we can start to again
auto-remediate, auto-optimize,
and auto-improve what is
taking place as part of this,
and overall drive this automation
and predictive insights
to really provide the best for you,
to prevent those fires from
taking place in the first place.
And overall, what we're getting to here
is that obviously logs quite
often are very technical,
utilized for a lot of different things.
But one of the things we
are seeing a lot more power
and a lot more benefit with logs
is because they have so much rich context
and so much rich information,
they're quite often powerful
from a business data perspective.
And the ability to have that information
directly connected to your IT information
is also very powerful.
Because of course it means that
you can start to understand,
like Alex was talking about earlier,
about how you can understand
the revenue impact
of these incidents or problems
that are taking place.
You can start to understand in real time
that actual visibility,
to understand your entire
end-to-end processes, you know,
your end-to-end journeys
that customers go through
and where that impact is taking place,
where you are having these
significant issues and so on.
And this has all been
provided because, as I said,
all this information is
being topology-mapped,
being stored in context
so that everything is relatable
and everything is understood
within its domain.
Now, overall,
we're also obviously trying
to really drive towards
that proactive AWS operations.
So as mentioned earlier,
we've got that direct AWS integration,
which allows us to easily capture
all of the key AWS telemetry information.
Now, we're also able to leverage
all of those cloud tags.
So bringing in your actual
cloud tagging strategy
directly into the Dynatrace platform
so that you're not having to recreate,
you're not having to build
new tagging strategies
and provide additional complexity.
We can inherit the tagging strategy
you've already got in your cloud
and bring it directly into Dynatrace.
So again, whether you want
to go and look at a log
or a trace or a metric,
we're literally pushing those cloud tags
to the actual signals that
are actually taking place.
So again, you can query, filter,
do whatever you want with the information.
And again,
our AI can obviously utilize
all that information as well
so that we can ensure that
you've got that deep insights
into your AWS estate for
obviously these key three areas.
So whether that is the sort of
auto-prevention side of things,
so whether that's things
like capacity planning
and forecasting of the events,
whether it's things like
auto-remediation, you know,
with the root cause analysis
and obviously putting out those fires
before they hopefully
impact any of your users,
or whether it's auto-optimization
where, you know,
we are looking at resource optimization,
we are looking at
identifying misconfigurations
and improvements that can be made.
And I think it's always
interesting to see,
especially when you start to
get down the root of the AI
and the auto-optimization
side, is where, you know,
the human oversight
comes into these things.
Because a lot of the time,
things like auto-remediation
aren't too difficult,
you know, whether it's scaling things out,
spinning up boxes, change configuration
or whatever it may be.
But when you start to
get around optimization,
you have to have goals,
you have to have insights
provided by a human.
Because of course if you
just basically give an AI,
I want to make this as
performant as possible,
it's gonna cost a lot of money
'cause it's gonna obviously
scale out everything.
But if you're gonna, you know,
obviously go the other way and go,
"Oh, I want to make it
as secure as possible,"
it'll probably just switch it all off.
So again, you know, you
need to give it the realms,
the goals, the boundaries
that are associated with that,
and optimization is that balance.
And so that's always, I find,
quite an interesting one to
look at from an AI perspective.
So to sort of finish off and summarize,
really, Dynatrace is trying to help you
scale your log management cost effectively
and unify and contextualize
all of that information,
all of the log information
with all of the other signals that exist,
and really to enable that
proactive and AI-driven insights
for you to take place.
Now, not only does this help reduce
your mean time to resolution,
but it also helps you track
end-to-end business journeys
and obviously make those
data-driven business decisions
that we were talking about before as well.
And obviously, with AWS,
we can proactively help
with the AWS operations to
do the auto-remediation,
the auto-prevention and auto-optimization.
So I'm gonna invite Frank
and Alex back up on stage.
We're gonna have a quick sort of Q&A
sort of style of things
to finish this off.
- Awesome. If you want to sit down.
I'm gonna do rapid fire,
'cause we only have a
couple of minutes left.
Awesome. Alright.
I always like this kind of Q&A setup
because it's a little bit more,
you know, less structured.
And if there's any questions
that you really need to be answered,
you can just scream them in.
But unfortunately, we don't
have a mic to go around,
but I have a couple here
that I wanted to clarify.
And the first one is on culture.
That was a big thing of
one of your three pillars.
And I just wanted to know, like,
how did you actually manage that?
Because culture is a beautiful thing,
but it's also really difficult to impact
and make changes on.
Like, how did you manage that transition?
- So for us, I think,
first of all, it was identifying
the right set of people
who could be our culture
carriers across the organization,
and work out how we could
meaningfully engage them
in the process of looking
at the observability problem
and working out how we could move forward.
And then it was a question
of how do we meaningfully
carry that message
out to the rest of our organization.
We did that through things like
Dyna Days, through support,
through AWS, running GameDays
in combination with Dynatrace.
And through sharing
internal documentation,
things like this maturity
model that you saw earlier.
It's hard, though.
Culture eats strategy for breakfast.
As much as you want to
build out strategies
that drive observability and other pieces,
unless you pay attention
to that cultural piece,
you will fail.
- How long did it take you?
- Oh it was a good year-long
process, to be honest.
- Yeah, and did Dynatrace
somehow contribute
to making it a little easier?
- Massively.
So I mentioned Dyna Day.
This is a day that hopefully
you're not all about to
ask Dynatrace to provide,
but I think they will be in certain cases,
where some of the Dynatrace
account team come out,
spend some time with your engineers,
work out what their challenges are,
work out what the lever are to pull,
and help them understand
what great can look like
from an observability position.
Things like the Dynatrace-AWS
GameDay, incredibly powerful.
Running a game day is a
huge thing. It's great fun.
It's really engaging for
our engineering community.
And to work with two partners
like Dynatrace and AWS,
absolutely fantastic.
- Nice, and are you
running a lot of these?
- Quite a few, to be fair.
I mean, it does vary customer by customer.
I think every customer is different,
and where the cultural changes
are needed also vary as well.
I think overall a lot of it is about,
I guess, enablement and involvement.
So the more that people can be involved,
the more people can be
enabled, the easier that is.
'Cause obviously Alex talks about,
through the presentation,
things like the return
on investment was easy
and sort of insane how how much could be
sort of returned very quickly.
But it's all about, you know,
how much is it of a
benefit to that individual.
And so how do we bring them in?
Sometimes it is through the AWS GameDays
and things like that
where sometimes it is,
to an extent, a more
playful, fun thing to do,
to bring the in.
But they all have a level of enablement
sort of as part of that.
- Yeah, and I think there's always so many
little pockets of knowledge
that how you can actually be enabled.
And everybody that's in the audience
has very much leaned in,
and you're here and you're, you know,
but how this is being translated
to the larger organizations
that are behind you,
I think that's always nice to kind of get
the best practices from.
- I think that's exactly why
we started with detractors,
people who didn't believe
that they had an observability problem,
because they were the most
powerful groups to convince.
Once you get those people aligned,
you can bring the rest of
the organization along.
Those people who are enthusiastic, who are
promoters of observability,
quite often are not the people
you need to persuade to change.
- Yeah.
Switching a little bit, five minutes.
I want to talk a little bit
about like mixed environments.
You have of course a lot of signals
coming from OTel collectors
from the OneAgent,
from different platforms.
How did you manage that?
Because no one comes to
the table being just,
you know, vanilla.
And then there's a lot
of complexity to it.
- No, absolutely.
I spent a lot of time talking
about our previous logs piece.
We also had a previous
observability platform
provided by another vendor,
and we'd gone down a strongly
OTel-opinionated route
with that implementation.
OTel was spread out across
all of our backend services.
Conversely, our frontend services
had no form of observability coverage
aside from the logging piece.
What we really wanted was a
full end-to-end experience.
And what we learned on our journey
is that with everything
there is a compromise.
Our strongly OTel-opinionated pattern
was great for providing
a standardized interface
across all of our backend services.
But when we started trying to
connect frontend user actions
through to the backend ecosystem,
staying pure OTel in
that backend ecosystem,
we were losing as much as we were gaining.
So for us, we have just been
through our first big period on Dynatrace.
We know we have more work to do.
And I think that work will
be moving towards a position
where at least our first layer of services
behind our frontends
on natively implemented
with Dynatrace OneAgent.
Because we believe, although
that will compromise
our singular OTel-everywhere vision,
we will get a better experience
and more value from
the Dynatrace platform.
- Yeah, and speaking of
distributed or, you know,
tool sprawl have a lot of different ones.
Like, I would assume that
everybody in the audience
uses probably more than
one observability provider.
How do you actually make that unified
or unifying observability possible.
Maybe for you, Jon.
- Yeah, I mean,
as you said, most companies
do have a lot of observability
tools and vendors out there.
It does range across the board.
I think a lot of the time it is that focus
on your initial areas or
initial places of focus
where you can get the most amount of value
and then expanding from there.
'Cause I think what you
end up seeing a lot of
is that it's not just, I say,
the quality of each vendor
or each tool that's necessarily the issue;
quite often it is the
siloed nature of that data,
which is an even bigger issue.
The fact that each team
has their own tool,
their own source of truth
means that you end up
with this whole
finger-pointing and war rooms
that are taking place.
And, you know, bringing that together
is one key part of that, I think.
And so even if that information
is coming from different areas,
that's why I'd say a lot of the time,
if you can focus on the
applications, the teams
where you can get the most
amount of value quickly,
it can then expand and sort of
grow very quickly from that.
Because you can then start to bring in
the various different tools
from various different teams
and grow from that, rather
than taking one layer,
like logs as an example, across the board.
Of course, that can be value
let's say from a licensing
replacement perspective,
and you know, cost-savings on that front.
But of course, if you can,
let's say take everything
within a particular team,
you know, all the different
telemetry data together,
you will get significantly more value
than taking one data
type across the board.
- Yeah, and I mean,
I see this from my perspective as well.
Like, the number of customers
that come to AWS and say,
"We have so many different vendors.
How do we figure this out?
Can you help us consolidate of one?
Which one do you recommend?"
Like, that's really kind of top of mind
for a lot of customers.
What about automation?
There's a lot of capability
that Dynatrace brings to the table.
Were you able to sort of
walk the whole nine yards
with automated and automated workflows?
- It's a journey we've certainly started.
So when I talked through
our technology stack,
I failed to mention the
elephant in the room.
We do have a little bit of Kubernetes.
We use Kubernetes specifically
for our AI workloads.
And this is more traditional AI
where we're using our own models
and we're running on our own EKS clusters,
the actual computation
around those models.
We have a set of challenges around that.
We scale up and down quite
quickly as an organization.
And when you're running
on GPU-bound hardware,
we were finding that scaling up and down
with the base set of Kubernetes
metrics was not effective.
The boot-up time is just too long.
EKS has a fantastic
feature called warm pools
which allows you to solve this problem.
But equally, we didn't want
a load of spare G5 instances
sat around twiddling their thumbs,
because they're not the
cheapest thing in the world.
Dynatrace helped us solve
this by predictively saying,
"We can see pressure
on your NVIDIA drivers
is looking like this.
You are getting to the point
where you're going to need to scale soon.
I will add one node into the warm pool."
And that can then scale,
be elegantly scaled upon
to without a long delay.
- Got it. Anything to add?
- I mean, we're basically out of time.
But yeah, I mean, overall,
there obviously is a
lot of potential there.
And I think it is, you know,
as with Alex and Storio group,
it is quite often that staged approach.
You do often start with certain scenarios,
certain areas where
you can see easy value,
and then grow it out over
time as things evolve.
And as of course everybody gets behind it
and gets involved in that and, you know,
then automates and gets a lot more value.
- Awesome.
You were emphatically raising your hand.
If you can scream really loudly.